make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so we are back again with our
coverage of
avengers now this is where things really
begin to pick up
right this is where things get really
really cool and that's that's that was
one of the big issues that i think i
kind of had
with hickman's avengers run is it starts
off super strong and then there comes a
point where it looks like marvel was
just wanting hickman to kill time for a
little while which is kind of what he
did
right now some of it was him setting
things up but for the most part it was
just like a small little thing here and
there right like you guys saw
the alternate reality evil version of
thor you saw his hammer you saw the
alternate reality version of bruce
those two things will come back later
but it was by no means necessary to
write like a full on four issue
story in order to achieve that right
that could have been done in the blink
of an eye
but what this particular part of the
story does is it really sort of
it's kind of the shifting of the status
quo right how things used to be versus
how things are
or at least how things are going forward
and what we end up doing here is
basically picking up with steve rogers
having a dream right now this dream is
basically the sequence of events that we
saw
in the very in the very beginning of the
story right when we saw the first new
avengers arc where the infinity gauntlet
was destroyed and all that kind of stuff
that's what this
is right it's captain america getting
the infinity gauntlet when the group was
first formed or first reformed in order
to face off against the incursions
and and you know of course as all the
gems were basically destroyed except for
the time jim just disappeared
but the idea here is that this is
essentially captain america
recalling all those moments right that
whole entire
sequence and it kind of goes exactly the
way that it did initially right which is
to say
that when when the infinity gauntlet
fails the
the group basically starts talking about
this idea of destroying worlds that if
the destruction of their universe hinges
on another universe's earth colliding
with their own then just destroy that
universe's earth and call it a day right
do whatever you have
to do in order to preserve the existing
universe and it's kind of one of these
interesting things right because
initially captain america was was
wildly against it he was like no we're
not going to destroy any alternate
realities we can find a way to figure
this out and that's a good moral
sentiment to have
but what happens when you get to a point
where you cannot well there are no other
options right when there are no other
options to explore
and that's why captain america's memory
was wiped and that's why he was cast out
because
ultimately he didn't have the fortitude
to do what needed to be done and that
was the nature of this group right
to make the tough choices to do the
things that other people just weren't
really able or willing to do
and that's the weakness of captain
america right call it moral
righteousness call it him doing the
right thing you know whatever the case
is
at the end of the day when it hits the
fan and you have to make the choice it's
going to lead to other people being
sacrificed captain america can't do it
and that's what made things so
intriguing is because he's there for
kind of the moral support
but he's not one of the heavy hitters
when it comes to the thinking power when
it comes to brain power he's not on par
with tony stark or reed richards or
t'challa he's not the leader of a
kingdom like name with a submariner
who's willing to do whatever it takes to
preserve the kingdom of atlantis right
he's not that kind of a guy he's a guy
who'll do whatever he can to make sure
other people survive but at the end of
the day if the survival of others means
the death of himself
then that's a problem as far as this
group's concerned right like captain
america would spare another universe and
sacrifice his own that kind of seems to
be the case and that sort of
selflessness cannot survive
in this kind of scenario and that's why
his mind was wiped he was banished and
that was the end of that the problem
with this
is that captain america now remembers
everything now the reason why this
happens and it's important to explain
this
the reason why this happens is because
of an event that marvel had called
original sin now original sin
is one of these events that marvel
created whereby it was a means to either
kind of propel
existing stories you know into a more
suitable direction
or to just kind of you know introduce
new concepts for example he had a guy by
the name of midas right it was like the
midas empire this guy could touch stuff
and turn the gold one of the dumbest
things to come out of that was like his
daughter took over nobody cared right
nobody cared about that what made
original sin
cool is all the small little things that
we got right because
with original sin what you ended up
getting was the death of the watcher and
one of the watchers
eyes was secured by a villain called the
or now the orb was dumb he was just a
giant eyeball right he was basically a
really useless villain but he you know
when you had like all the various
superheroes
facing off against him he ended up
revealing the eye and then blasting them
with the secrets of the watcher
basically being that the watcher sees
everything right a lot of you guys
probably know who the watcher is who
watches the watcher he sits on the moon
he doesn't really act
right he's the guy that basically told
the fantastic four galactus is coming
that kind of a thing
at least in the original galactus
trilogy but uwatu sees everything so the
lies people tell themselves
the secrets that have been kept
everything that this group's been doing
behind the back of the avengers right
like traveling from world of world and
the map makers and the the you know the
rumor of the ivory kings and the the the
black priests and all that kind of stuff
while all that's been hidden the watcher
saw it and knows about all of it
right and so with captain america
basically having his mind wiped by by
doctor strange the fact that that
happened
has been revealed to him through the
events of original sin now you can find
the whole original sim playlist on the
youtube channel right you know
on the comments playing youtube channel
you can find it all there you know and
and it works you know for what it is but
the idea here
is is that with steve rogers basically
waking up he realizes
that in the aftermath of what's happened
at least is his mind being white between
the time that happened and the and the
current moment
he's figured out a few things right and
so what he ends up doing is of course
grabbing hawkeye and grabbing black
widow who will be exceedingly important
to the future of the story along with
thor hyperion and star brand now to face
off against tony stark
this may seem overkill but it's not
right it's actually not
and the reason why is because once they
get into the lab of tony stark and he's
confronted by steve rogers then all this
gets an explanation
right the response to steve is you've
been lying to us it's time the lies stop
right it's time that all these lies come
to an end and when tony's kind of like
what are you talking about the response
to steve is
i remember and that's when tony stark
begins to pick up on what steve's
talking about that he recalls everything
that happened in the very beginning of
this story
tony's response is okay let's go talk
about it man and steve just kind of like
you've done it haven't you like you've
destroyed worlds like you've you've had
other earths that have shown up here
from other realities and you've
destroyed them to save our own and again
i side with that right i side with that
idea like
yeah i mean hey look it kind of sucks
but sorry about your luck it's just
it's the way things work you don't fix a
sandwich for the hungry kids across the
street
if your kids are hungry at home right
charity starts at home
my home that's the way it works you can
call it selfish if you want to not
really right i mean
if you're a superhero and you're
occupying earth and you realize that
like your your earth and your entire
universe could be destroyed if another
earth crashes into it well then i'm
sorry about those guys but you gotta go
that's just the way that's
the way it is right practical it's the
reasonable thing to do and it makes
sense and so because of that
you know with captain america asking the
question whose moral compass was it they
crashed first right who was it that
wasn't that who was it that broke first
the response of tony is
you did because you didn't have the
fortitude to do what needed to be done
you're a half measure and
captain america freaks right immediately
just like punches the crap out of tony
stark and then when everybody's like
what in the world is going on that's
what he revealed
they've reformed right like the
illuminati's return and that's what
makes things so crazy is because he
basically ends up saying that he
ends up revealing to hyperion to
starbrand all these guys in their spare
time
that like reed richards and black
panther and name with a submariner and
black bolt doctor strange tony stark and
even now well he doesn't really know
about bruce banner at the moment but
like they've been jumping around
from university like just destroying
other worlds right that's what's been
happening here and the other crazy thing
about that
is that that you know steve rogers kind
of hits on the idea that tony stark's
been using them and that's true all
right here's here's you know and that's
why i've kind of waited up to this point
to basically explain
exactly what's going on here and why
this all shifts so the way this works is
as you guys have noticed
you have the avengers set of events and
then you have the new avengers set of
events right the the incursions the map
makers all that kind of stuff you've had
basically two stories going on at the
same time
the whole creation of the avengers
machine by tony stark would just say
a project that he was working on with
steve rogers to expand the avengers
roster to face off against various
threats that was a distraction
so long as captain america is doing that
he's not paying attention to anything
else he's not noticing the events of
like the incursions and so on and so
forth because
from from tony stark's perspective
captain america is basically a
two-dimensional guy and in a lot of ways
he is captain america is basic and he's
two-dimensional he's not really really
really smart right he's really good at
like rallying troops and leading them
towards a particular cause but at the
end of the day
he's a soldier right he does what he's
told to do that's basically what it is
what tony stark had to do was
was engineer a situation to where
captain america was doing what he was
instructed to do without realizing it to
basically say like it's steve rogers
idea right to kind of
curtail his thinking process sort of you
know move things and put the pieces in a
particular way so that when captain
america looked back on the whole
avengers machine he saw himself he saw
it as kind of a reflection of his ideals
that tony stark was able to bring into
fruition right that's how it was all
engineered by tony it's probably the
single greatest act of manipulation
in the entire history of the marvel
universe right it's huge
and and that was the whole point is
basically to have the avengers face off
against various threats right that's
it the builders were a credible threat
and nobody really saw the builders
coming right the builders were something
that had to be sorted out that had to be
dealt with
but for for reid and and tony stark and
black panther and all them you know
because the incursions and all that the
arrival of the builders was fortuitous
right like the avengers from this
alternate reality you know that were
brought in by advanced idea mechanics
that was fortuitous all these these
little these things that basically
happened that just
happened to happen at the right time and
benefited tony and his whole crew
right so that's that's really what's
been taking place here it's just been
manipulation on behalf of tony stark and
and when he's confronted by that by
steve rogers the response to tony is
yeah i did man i did what i needed to do
in order to make sure that we could
achieve our goal
because if you had been left to your own
devices and if you had been made aware
of what was happening you would have
done what you always do you would have
gotten
in the way you would have slowed down
progress you would have been the source
of the problem
not the source of a solution and so the
response of captain america is it's not
going to work
and the response of iron man is that's
fine man but you have to understand
this is my workshop you've walked into
the lion's den you've come into iron
man's office
into the place where he works and
challenged me to a fight understand my
friend when you fight me
in my workshop like this you're not
fighting me you're fighting a legion
of me and every single iron man armor
comes pouring out right every single one
and it's cool to see because these are
enough guys to basically take those iron
man suits down but
it's just so many versions of these iron
man suits with so many wild abilities
the problem with that is that when that
happens suddenly the time stone pops up
at the most inopportune time the time
stone pops up it snatches up captain
america
and it snatches up black widow and it
snatches up hawkeye and it whisks them
48 years into the future with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob for if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you